[Music]  [Music]  yeah but I think we take one h78 weekend  yeah I think it's trying to over  complicate things there is unnecessary  we do second issue have we discussed  what's on your right a teddy bear or and  I or some clothes I I really can't see  it from what is it today it's an  elephant  yeah okay and dessert is the other name  know what Lauren's never tried to  address the elephant in the room  I love it well-played sir  well-played give yourself oh well sir  that you give yourself  [Music]  [Music]  Wow Knight c3 Bishop a5 that's the  plunder look Wow  etcd Queen b3 come on Maxie no this with  a head porn on III good you have to  please white lady young yeah yurid sleek  design stuff big wins do that from  resting that's a mess Wow  I'm Jenna and I don't see will  opportunity by think you've said it was  over already  no I don't see any nad hug  you